>>> AS THE WORLD WAITS FOR
PUTIN'S NEXT MOVE, IT'S HIS
CONTINUED THREAT OF NUCLEAR WAR
THAT HAS PRESIDENT BIDEN
DOUBLING DOWN ON A CHILLING
WARNING IN AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH CNN.
>> HE, IN FACT, CANNOT CONTINUE
WITH IMPUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
USE OF A TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON
AS IF IT'S A RATIONAL THING TO
DO.
THE MISTAKES GET MADE.
AND THE MISCALCULATION COULD
OCCUR.
NO ONE CAN BE SURE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND IT COULD END IN
ARMAGEDDON.
>> BUT THE PRESIDENT ALSO
STRESSED HE STILL DOESN'T THINK
PUTIN WILL ACTUALLY RESORT TO
NUKES DESPITE HIS LOSSES AND
DESPERATION.
CNN'S KAITLAN COLLINS IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH MORE.
A CAREFULLY WORDED MESSAGE FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: HE SEEMS TO BE, YOU
KNOW, REALLY CLARIFYING WHAT HE
WAS SAYING IN THAT CLOSED DOOR
FUND-RAISER LAST WEEK WHEN HE
FIRST WAS TALKING ABOUT THE IDEA
OF ARMAGEDDON HERE AND SAYING
THAT HE BELIEVES BASICALLY THE
WORLD IS ON THE CLOSEST BRINK OF
NUCLEAR WAR THAT IT HAS BEEN
SINCE THE 1960s WHEN THE CUBAN
MISSILE CRISIS HAPPENED TRYING
TO CLARIFY WHAT HE WAS SAYING
THERE AND ALSO TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HE THINKS ABOUT PUTIN
OVERALL, SAYING HE DOES BELIEVE
HE IS STILL A RATIONAL ACTOR,
THAT DESPITE WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM SOME OTHER WORLD LEADERS
AND INTELLIGENCE EXPERTS AND
WHAT THEY'VE SPECULATED ABOUT
PUTIN'S MINDSET HERE BUT WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID TO JAKE
TAPPER WAS HE DOES BELIEVE HE IS
A RATIONAL ACTOR WHO MADE A
DECISION THAT WAS NOT RATIONAL
BY SENDING HIS TROOPS INTO
UKRAINE, HE SAYS HE BELIEVES HE
BASICALLY MISJUDGED THE
SITUATION AND THOUGHT WHAT HE
WAS GOING INTO WAS GOING TO LOOK
A LOT DIFFERENT THAN IT DOES.
HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD JAKE TAPPER.
>> I THINK HE IS A RATIONAL
ACTOR THAT MISCALCULATED.
HE THOUGHT THIS IS THE HOME OF
RUSSIA AND I THINK HE TOTALLY
MISCALCULATED.
>> Reporter: TODAY HE WAS
LEAVING THE INTERVIEW AND SAID
HE BELIEVES THE LATEST RUSSIAN
ATTACKS ON CIVILIAN TARGETS ARE
BRUTAL, THAT THEY ARE BEYOND THE
PALE AND ASKED ABOUT A COMMENT
HE MADE YESTERDAY WHERE HE SAID
HE DOESN'T SEE HIMSELF SITTING
DOWN TO MEET WITH PUTIN BUT
OVERALL IF THERE IS A SITUATION
LIKE AT THE G20 SUMMIT WITH
WORLD LEADERS GATHERING IN BALI
IN NOVEMBER AND IT WAS TO TALK
ABOUT BRITTNEY GRINER OR ONE OF
THE DETAINED MIAMERICANS, THAT
SOMETHING HE COULD SEE FEASIBLE.
ANY MOVEMENT IN THAT SPACE, HE
SAID, QUOTE, NOT WITH PUTIN.
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN HIS
INTERVIEW WITH JAKE TAPPER LAST
NIGHT WHERE HE SAYS HE BELIEVES
PUTIN IS RATIONAL.
HOWEVER, HE SAYS PUTIN NEEDS TO
CHANGE HIS BEHAVIOR.
NO RATIONAL LEADER WOULD DO
THIS.
>> HOW REALISTIC DO YOU THINK IT
IS PUTIN WOULD USE A NUCLEAR
TACTICAL WEAPON.
>> I DON'T THINK HE WILL BUT
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
THE IDEA THAT A WORLD LEADER
SAYS HE MAY USE A TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPON IN UKRAINE, HE,
IN FACT, CANNOT CONTINUE WITH
IMPUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE USE
OF A TACKTY TALL NUCLEAR WEAPON
AS IF IT'S A RATIONAL THING TO
DO.
THE MISTAKES GET MADE AND THE
MISCALCULATION COULD OCCUR, NO
ONE CAN BE SURE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND IT COULD END IN
ARMAGEDDON.
>> THE ARMAGEDDON LINE HE USED
AT A FUND-RAISER IN PRIVATE.
PUTIN NEEDS TO STOP THIS BECAUSE
SOMEBODY MIGHT SEE SOME ACTION,
MISINTERPRET WHAT IT IS AND MAKE
A MISTAKE EVEN IF PUTIN ISN'T
GOING TO USE A TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT GETS EVERYBODY ON EDGE.
>> THAT'S BIDEN WHEN HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT OR WHEN HIS AIDE WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE ARMAGEDDON
COMMENT AFTER HE MADE IT
INITIALLY, THIS IS THE PRESIDENT
TRYING TO BE VERY REALISTIC AND
VERY STARK ABOUT WHAT THE STAKES
ARE, YOU KNOW, THE INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS HAVE SAID THERE'S NO
CHANGE TO THE NUCLEAR POSTURE.
THEY DON'T EXPECT ANYTHING
IMMINENT ANY TIME SOON BUT HE'S
BEING VERY CLEAR SAYING THAT
THIS COULD BE -- WE COULD BE
HEADED BACK TO 1962 AND THIS
COULD BE THE GREATEST CHALLENGE
SINCE THEN.
THAT'S THE POINT HE GETS ACROSS.
I THINK THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
TIMES DURING THE CRISIS, DURING
THIS WAR WHERE HE HAS BEEN MUCH
MORE AGGRESSIVE IN HIS RHETORIC
BUT HE IS CERTAINLY STANDING BY
IT NOW BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT HE
WANTS TO CONVEY TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT COULD HAPPEN
IF SOMETHING GOES HORRIBLY
WRONG.
>> BOTH PRESIDENTS ARE EXPECTED
TO BE AT THE G20 COMING UP.
THAT WOULD BE A CHANCE GIVEN A
DICEY POLITICS TO MAKE THAT CASE
WITH PUTIN.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS I DON'T THINK
SO UNLESS --
>> LOOK, I HAVE NO INTENTION OF
MEETING WITH HIM, BUT, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF HE CAME TO ME AT THE
G20 AND SAID I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE RELEASE OF GRINER, I'D
MEET WITH HIM.
I MEAN, IT WOULD DEPEND BUT I
CAN'T IMAGINE -- HE'S COMMITTED
WAR CRIMES AND SO I DON'T -- I
DON'T SEE ANY RATIONAL TO MEET
WITH HIM NOW.
>> A COUPLE INTERESTING POINTS
THERE.
ONE REPEATING AGAIN THAT PUTIN
HAS COMMITTED WAR CRIMES, TWO,
ALSO SAYING THAT THERE IS
OPENNESS TO MEETING WITH HIM BUT
ON AN ISSUE THAT DIRECTLY
INVOLVES THE U.S. AND RUSSIA,
THAT BEING THE DETAINMENT OF
BRITTNEY GRINER THEN WENT ON TO
SAY AS WELL THAT, LOOK, OUR
FOCUS RIGHT NOW IS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE INVASION OF UKRAINE
INVOLVING UKRAINE IN ANY TALKS
WITH PUTIN OR ANYONE ELSE.
HE EMPFA SIZED THAT AS WELL BUT
THE BRITTNEY GRINER ISSUE, THAT
IS INTERESTING AS OBVIOUSLY THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN FACING
PRESSURE AS WELL AT TIMES TO
MESSAGE MORE ABOUT THIS, TO TALK
MORE ABOUT THIS AS WELL AND TO
TAKE SOME ACTION ON HER RELEASE.